hundreds of thousands of people and
earthquake had devastated turkey and
Syria are waking up clinging to hope
some of their loved ones are still alive
rescue workers are digging through piles
of debris to find survivors as Aid
workers struggle to cope with the scale
of the disaster more than 8 600 people
are now confirmed dead the stories of
miraculous rescues are continuing to
come in a three-year-old boy was rescued
in karaman marash araf Khan was pulled
out of the rubble after 43 hours
bristle asserta has more from the city
that was the epicenter of the disaster
it's hard to imagine anyone could
survive this
but despite the odds a woman is found
alive
here in karaman maharash many lives have
been torn apart
many other lives have been lost all
together
[Music]
all buildings here are collapsed
completely destroyed there is no Trace
left there are no standing buildings we
have been waiting here since yesterday
help has just arrived unfortunately they
were late
the scale of the disaster is immersed
this is hatai near the Syrian border
apartment block after apartment block
has collapsed it will take days weeks
even months to find all the victims
and without heavy lifting Machinery
there is little residents can do to help
words are sticking to my throat crying
is no longer a remedy we expect
professional help we expect to see a
professional job we are not professional
as you see we are diving in the rubble
completely blind
those
some of those trapped have left voice
messages calling for help below the
Tangled methyl and concrete
in gaziante Rescuers called for complete
silence
they are listening for any sign of
survivors
[Music]
International rescue teams are arriving
here German and Turkish teams pool a 66
year old to save a team
[Music]
um
we couldn't use heavy equipment because
the rubble was so unstable and we were
afraid that the entire building could
collapse it really required manual work
we had to remove piece by piece
and that work continues Into the Night
as families shelter out in the open
this city was the was the center of the
earthquake that affected over 13 million
people in Turkey nearly a thousand
buildings have collapsed here there are
tens of people under this Rubble some of
them still alive waiting to be rescued
resource Al Jazeera karaman marash
we have two correspondents covering this
story from South Eastern Turkey let's go
first to Stephanie Decker she joins us
live from guzian tip in Tokyo and how
was the rescue operation going on there
now three days honors there still any
hope of finding anyone alive in the
rubble
other location that we've just returned
from it is a recovery operation it is no
longer a rescue operation around 80
people bodies at this stage the rescue
workers are saying are believed to be
under the rubble of this apartment
they're no longer hearing voices we just
came back from another location where we
saw a body being pulled from out from
the rubble he was a father his daughter
was there she was sobbing a lot of
family members were there absolutely
heartbreaking to see really one woman
talked to me and she described it as the
actual earthquake that night as they
slept to wake up being uh you know
around a minute and a half and she
described the buildings moving literally
like this so basically I'll let you Fadi
uh basically get him to film this is the
rubble of a large apartment block what
it looked like there's one right next to
it to the right and to give you a sense
of the scale
um that's what it pretty much was I'd
identical so this came down in an
instant people say as it started it just
collapsed upon itself you had a few
people pulled from the rubble here
yesterday but now as I say it's three
days on it's also bitterly cold it's
below zero the sun is now coming out and
starting to warm things somewhat but it
is extremely challenging and just
briefly
um you know the aid operation is going
on yesterday we arrived at gaziantep
with the Qatari eight flight and we saw
we were there for a couple of hours a
lot of teams coming in you had the
kuwaitis taking out heavy equipment also
cars Vehicles you have the qataris
bringing about 10 000 tents for those
displaced Medical Teams and Israeli team
arrived that are going to set up an
Israeli field Hospital Turkmenistan
aircraft it is a massive International
operation what is key now we're in
gaziantap which is a city that is pretty
accessible a lot of the city still
stands but you have far more remote
areas difficult to get to the roads are
broken literally broken that need
desperate help because people are trying
to remove this kind of rubble with their
hands still getting to survivors and as
we know under these circumstances it is
minutes and hours that count and day
thank you so much for that update that's
Stephanie Decker for us and gazian tip
we're going to go now to Bernard Smith
who is with us from Sean Lee offer in
Tokyo and how Bernard Hell Survivors
there coping obviously three days on
what are the conditions like for them
yeah
well Tom here in uh much of the city
wasn't affected by the Quake but there
were patches where buildings fell down
and this is one this is what happened to
the building behind me now actually a
small bit of good news from here they
call the four-year-old boy out of the
rubble from here in the middle of the
night 47 hours after half building
collapsed sadly also the boy's mother's
body was recovered and his father is
still buried in there somewhere six
bodies have been recovered but this
four-year-old boy found alive and what's
particularly interesting is I don't know
how clear your picture is but all around
us the buildings are still standing and
yet this one building has fallen down so
you have to ask yourself why now in
Turkey since 2007 there have been strict
regulations about uh Building Safety so
that we are able to withstand
earthquakes all of these buildings we're
told around here were built after 2007
but the difference with the one where
collapsed locals are telling us is that
there was a supermarket in the basement
and when they make when they expand the
supermarket they cut down the pillars
that are the supporting pillars of the
building and that is why they think this
building has fallen down this is a
common practice they discovered in 1999
in Izmir the reason a lot of buildings
collapsed and others didn't of course
pillars were removed from the
supermarket or shops in the basement
underneath of course there'll be an
investigation that that is what people
living here believe is why this building
collapsed at the time okay thank you so
much Bernard uh for us and Sean Lee
offer in Tokyo
well in neighboring Syria crowds
chartered as white helmets rescue
workers pulled out survivors and
rebel-held idlib province
an entire family was pulled from one
collapsed building and taken to a
hospital and people in idlib were
already struggling after years of war
rescue and relief efforts are being
criticized as an adequate and hundreds
of buildings have collapsed there across
Syria more than 2 300 people have died
the UN says damaged roads a lack of
equipment and tough winter conditions
are hampering efforts to find survivors
also in Syria people in jinderas found
an infant alive her mother apparently
gave birth while she was buried in the
rubble of a five-story building the
newborn was found with her umbilical
cord still connected to her mother who
has since died
Adam is Oxfam Syria country director he
says Syria lacks the aid turkey is
receiving
unlike a turkey International Aid is not
coming to Syria at all and the situation
here is handled is being handled by the
government as we know the government's
capacity is very limited in terms of
rescue teams in terms of
equipment the Ministry of Health
reported as of yesterday uh close to 1
000 people
who lost their life uh 1500 injured and
still many people are under the rebel
and the government has very little
capacity I think it's very important to
keep in mind that this tuition in Syria
even before the earthquake was extremely
dire we're talking about 90 percent of
the population living under the poverty
line nine out of syrians cannot really
think where the next meal is coming from
so the situation here is very dire and
our teams are on the ground in Aleppo
City and also in rural area which is two
areas that are badly impacted in the
governorate the needs that are really
needs to be addressed very quickly
people need to have access to a clean
drinking water food shelter the supplies
are very limited people are in the
street in this really cold weather
very limited numbers of shelters that
have opened for people to get some
shelter